what I know about climate change is that
it's real it's man-made and there's
scientific evidence to back it up
climate change impacts my life most
directly through sea level rise climate
change would affect my generation and
the generation after me I think the
dumbest thing i've heard is Oklahoma
Senator Jim Inhofe saying that man
cannot change climate it's very very
cold out I respect their opinions but I
do not agree with their opinions like
they're easily visible physical factors
I would like to meet with Deb Fischer
and it's our Isaacson and Senator Purdue
I would like to meet with Senator Bill
Nelson and ask him what he intends to do
about climate change you have any sort
of education you have to be willing to
look at the world and think about it
objectively and see that there is indeed
climate change going on human beings are
a major cause and climate change if I
had the chance to speak with Marco Rubio
I would ask them to look closely at the
decades of studies released by NASA to
look towards policy to alleviate the
effects of climate change denying it is
i think detrimental and possibly
dangerous whatever happened to all this
global warming business the four foot
snow drift outside my door is apparently
a skeptic but counterintuitive as it may
see